hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inside now we just
opened up this weird machine and somehow
this machine continues to lead us into
the labyrinth of this thing whatever it
is there's a toolbox there what does
that mean that means someone who needed
to use tools was here at some point for
some reason that they built this thing
oh hi is this normal for you is this
normal everyday life for you what are
you filming why are you filming it am i
part of a big test ah why are they not
with that is so bizarre oh that's and
for there's another number
oh four it was three I saw twos and this
is four they have I seen fours I don't
know if I've seen fours as so bizarre
there's something to this not to make a
number pun but there's something to this
okay so what I need to do is I need to
make the water just enough that the door
opens which I think it does over yonder
way why was it so quiet in there can I
open this can I do something about this
nah okay that's weird
so maybe there's oh is that oh I didn't
even notice that that group of people in
there but that's no good how did I not
notice that how did I not notice that
how did I now notice that what is wait
this is different than what it was
before ah here we go uh I wouldn't have
noticed that I thought I was coming over
here for no reason who'd a thunk that I
needed a box room over here okay I'm
getting it now
sorry whoa boy what do i do uh don't do
it oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
see this guy driving a forklift a guy
driving a forklift like this is a normal
everyday occurrence box just randomly
plays box don't mind the box don't mind
the box don't mind the box you got your
kid ear you murdered another kid in
front of your kid he's got a baseball
cap and everything sad lil so I need to
drink a water I apologize the throat is
a little
oh boy are you done
okay I'm trusting you on this one
I suppose you're done which means that
I'm gonna be able to use this to my
advantage so what I need to do is I need
to lower the water level quote unquote
raise the water level and then move the
box into a position where it's on that
platform up there where I can properly
utilize it oh my legs okay lower so it's
gonna float right yonder there which is
super weird I get it it's very weird
okay so I just need to put it in a
position where it's over this thing yeah
what with the splash going up this all
weird the physics of this entire
universe just don't make sense anymore
none of this universe makes any sense
anymore but this is all just very
nonsensical ah hub LIF okay good job
very smooth on the recovery there so I
need you all the way up and then back
down right - dear right - dear okay and
then we need to jump on the Box we need
to get up on the box and everything will
be a-okay boy boy can boy you do boy
there we go and we're a winner we're a
winner winner winner winner and
hopefully we're gonna get some answers
very soon I may just make this episode
longer than the last ones if it takes
longer oh do I get to go back in my
buddy or those land mines water mine
sorry I'm stupid can I still breathe on
her wha I'm not gonna go down there
probably don't need to go down there
first let me go up first and then I'll
go down there oh never mind I can't even
go up I thought there was something okay
nevermind I was I was right on my first
instinct which was to go down far so I
need to do that ah boy hi hey how's is
normal for you how is this normal what
are you maintaining what kind of panel
needs maintenance told these bodies in a
weird stasis you bizarre bastards
can I hit this button on the way down I
hit this button on the way down it yeah
oh I thought I had it I thought I had it
but he didn't have it what does this do
whoa hey that's not good
where are we about to uh I'm sorry
oh I'm sorry why are you still following
me why do you still worship me have I
been given the powers oh you're just
weird blobs
oh you're weird blob little like that
there's another number for your weird
blobs
oh you're weird blobs ooh okay this is a
thing okay then so I need to push that
button I'm not even gonna bother he
named you your blob one through nine
geez UM's ah wrong way
stupid blobs throw me up mmm
higher higher higher you stupid blobs
are you weak because you've been soaking
in water for so long that your bodies
are just nothing but mush probably okay
so we need something to deal with that
but apparently you guys aren't good
enough because you can't throw hard you
need to learn to throw better you'd
think that the the heftier blobs would
be able to do this better but maybe wait
hang on maybe I'm doing something wrong
it's entirely possible that I'm doing
something wrong I just want to walk all
this way if it's not for nothing mmm
there's a window over here but I don't
think that's gonna actually help
anything
yeah that's close it's better throw than
you were doing straight up that's for
sure no okay so this obviously isn't it
if it didn't work the first time it's
not gonna work a third time so there's
got to be something else
oh man the head on that one with the
bandages oh this is gross
oh so disgusting I mean you're all
lovely people blob one through nine ten
eleven I don't know how many of you are
so I must have missed something
fundamental over here like this body
gains that body oh oh oh it's still
twitching
oh it's twitching oh that one's still
twitching oh oh okay so what happens if
I use them to get the water level up
again Kurt chuckles okay so the water
level comes back down I don't think
that's enough for them to throw them the
whoa now water came down a lot
can you guys throw me back no okay so
you can't throw me back oh but that
might have done something else else ah
here we go okay now I'm getting it now
I'm getting it sorry sorry I'm not sorry
you're horrible horrible monstrosity zan
I don't want to be around
oh they're following me good their
leader they know they know what's up so
if I fall down to that sign with the
weird would you let me just make sure
there's nothing up above nope nothing up
above so maybe I'm gonna hate it on the
way down
II I got it yeah follow me
thanks guys follow me you're weirdos
hello
you want to join our party apparently
yes you do about you oh that guy was
mopping he's joining anyway so these
guys have been assigned a menial task
they'd been programmed for some reason I
have a power I have a power to attract
to monstrosities I don't think the other
ones in what I didn't know to Bo
well you all survived but I had some
trouble there what
didn't you warn me that there was a pit
coming up I would have been very helpful
to me okay so you're gonna throw me
across throw me throw me Tommy throw me
that's putting a lot of faith and you
don't that guy guys guys guys what the
hell guys okay someone was smoking here
like recently oh they're running why are
they running what's happening what's
happening out there hmm I get they're
just getting away oh why so I get
something in my teeth now you guys don't
need to know about my personal problems
but my thought is that they're gonna
catch me oh they did thanks guys you
guys are not the best but I guess you
guys are now stuck here permanently but
you guys are all right thank you thank
you guys and gals if there are gals
among you oh oh oh okay okay so I guess
I'm not go that's not what I thought was
gonna happen but I guess this is helpful
don't get squashed
okay so ah goddamn it now what okay so
they can't go that way they must be able
to go this way and it's just gonna be a
convoluted route a follow-the-leader is
it mmm okay Wow that's as simple as that
yet doofus I come with me come with me
follow me follow me take my hand
follow me okay anyway and let it they
let it did it is us is that Vladimir
again trailing up the rear like a Lulu
loser like a loser all these guys are
losers but they're my losers so I keep
them around for stuff I can't believe
that I've like grown accustomed this
this is this normal now for me which is
just bizarre like hanging around with
these [ __ ] is somehow not wash it is
somehow normal whoa what is this what is
this what is this I don't know what this
is that's why I'm asking what the chairs
oh man that's so cool so cool I wanna
know I want to know I want to be the
very best whoops come on don't fail guys
huh all right bye have fun I'm going
into the big building that everyone else
seems to be sprinting in do maybe I'm
just trying to sprint to the
self-destruct button
maybe I've actually got a lot of
malicious intent cuz I can't just be
running for my own survival anymore
someone was here recently I'm running
for malicious revenge purposes so
someone's calling about a bad thing
something bad happened I know what
oh gosh so they do bleed that is a thing
what is this what is it huh hi for you
why are you here okay what do you what
are you doing okay bye
you don't pay me no mind oh hi don't
mind me don't strangle me like everybody
else does what are we all looking at
what are we all looking at here what's
happening
Rasch get out of the way okay don't mind
us at oh wait here
alright I'll take this with me don't
mind you guys do whatever you're doing I
don't know what you're doing
I'll just take this goddamn I'm so
confused show me show me the mystery I
want to know get on the thing goddamn
and get on the thing and they're off
goddamn it get on the thing I want to
know I want to know the mystery I want
to know what's going on I want to know
what's going on so badly oh man what am
I gonna have no maybe I'm just going to
get a better vantage point
maybe that's what I've been doing this
whole time I've just been running to get
a view of whatever the hell they've been
looking at this whole time oh man could
be but who knows what is it what is it
what is it ah what is so fascinating you
Oh what is so amazing what's so amazing
I want to know
oh man that's totally by design - that's
totally by design it's meant to be like
oh it's so good everyone stopped what
they're doing for ever and ever and they
just came to come a run and look at this
whatever the hell it is damn it and
they're taunting me they're tantalizing
me it's so close right there Marky move
you can no more day to get you know no
good
okay I think there's another thing to
disarm up here cuz I'm following the
yellow lines and that usually leads to
places where that is the thing maybe
what is that what's that sign mean oh oh
this is the end of the road oh if I
didn't unlocked all of them oh I would
have been here I would have been able to
open this thing I would have been able
to get a secret oh okay but I was not
nearly observant enough for that man but
I only got three of them and that makes
sense okay so for all you completionists
out there you've got an objective to
accomplish when you try this stuff here
so don't miss out on that there's
probably something really good and you
can find out what it is I don't know you
can look it up in the video but I highly
recommend getting it for yourself like
when I play games like these I cannot
recommend playing it for yourself enough
it's not that I can't recommend playing
it are you playing it for yourself but
it's just man the developers put so much
love into some of these games and
they're so cool they're so well made and
they got so much intrigue it's just
amazing to see so please support the
developers in whatever way you can
what what is this oh I want to know show
me oh where am I good okay turning away
from the big sphere or whatever it is
be smart about this Hey all right go
down Bubba cuz apparently we've been
nothing but going down this whole time I
don't even know where we escape from I
mean did we escape from like an
encampment of those people that will be
herded into things this feels very end
of the road yeah boy yeah boy
oh okay that was one one thing that I
did the thing of don't know what happen
no no I feel the need to constantly
destroy everything around here okay so
whoa what was that
hello what happened it's too strong I go
in no not yet okay so there's another
switch up here let me go flip that since
I'm such an a mood to randomly flip
switches everywhere I go
okay fans are off now maybe I can go
into this thing maybe hmm no not in
there but at least down here
okay got quiet I mean inside I want to
know what's inside the mystery box -
[ __ ] ah okay so alright okay I took
conundrum it can't be solved it's
insolvable it's unsolvable it can't be
done so I gotta find a way so there's
gotta be I don't know how to how would
you do that don't you do that how would
you do that how would you keep that open
so that you go above can't exactly wedge
anything in there that's not part of the
game mechanics so it's not that's not
what I should be thinking it's got to be
something that I can tie in here before
I go in there
um maybe I need to turn the fans back on
and maybe I need to just need to get
down there before it warms up again then
can push me all the way down and then I
can instantly throw me back up once I
get to the right point okay there we go
yeah that's the stuff oh yeah and we're
gonna go in 3 2 ha Bisky boink whoosh oh
boy whoa
I'm naked I got naked what the hell
hi why did I lose my clothes what are
you doing there
what what you don't want me to do
something you don't want me to do
something no no wait yeah let me get a
better idea of what the environment
around here is whoa oh hey oh man so do
I have a choice here I don't know what
the hell this thing is but it's
obviously they don't want me to pull the
plug on it what are they saying
no yeah no pointing they're pointing to
the thing why didn't they go in here why
are they waiting on me to do that so
they don't want me to pull this so I
have a choice my god this no no no this
no oh man ok so considering my curiosity
I'm more inclined to try this but then
again I don't know if there's a correct
path here or a interpretive path here
either way I don't think anyone's gonna
be happy in there oh oh it's it's a
bulbous amorphis mass oh god stop stop
grabbing me stop grabbing me you better
not assimilate me I don't know why I
lost my clothes but it's we know well
that wasn't good idea I think I
oh god no oh man oh geez oh my god this
did not turn out the way I thought it
would
oh man this could not have been this
kid's objective the whole time could it
have in Oh
oh boy unless it was
Oh God Oh God you can't stop me now oh
oh she's okay oh good lordy hello can I
assimilate you guys you want to be
assimilated into the pile come with me
maybe this was maybe this was the kids
objective this whole time because he was
one of these things and that's why
that's why they tried to stop him maybe
maybe that's why they were so desperate
to stop him because he was trying to do
this exact thing this whole time my
assumption
my assumption oh yeah you might want to
run buddy slow never mind you're fine
I came to the wrong exhibit well that
guy that guy lost his mind so yeah my
base assumption has been that this kid
is humid when in reality this kid may be
everything but human oh god the blob
okay so I gotta go people are just
watching Rudi oh man BRR BRR oh boy I'll
take this thank you I need this I need
it I need it
Oh need that hey on any of that I don't
know why I need it but I need it oh my
god
yeah so look maybe that was the thing
like my assumption that someone was
enslaving the human race when in reality
maybe that just wasn't it at all climb
up there well that wasn't exactly a
climb but I'll take it
yeah
job good job good job good job guys good
job guys
you're doing great proud of you ready
ready oh [ __ ] hey guys oh so good to see
humans again the vid since watching Oh
God hello do you work here who are you
hi
give me a hug hey buddy oh no oh let me
wash this off a little bit
don't flip upside down flip the bloody
side down what are you doing yeah wash
it off good god oh oh god there's still
some on there
you gotta get that clean it's not good
whoa whoa boom yeah flip over flip over
come on flip over flip flip for me there
we go that's a good flipper all right
we're out here we're out of here you
weirdo
have a deep dub dub boink okay can I
lift this No
okay apparently that's not working all
right so what do I need to do Oh
obviously in the water there was
something else
that leg was twitching there's something
over here probably ah okay I did not
know that this was a thing man we've got
a collective intelligence and it's all
this kid he's been the mastermind woof
missed try again
[ __ ] try one more time do a little
batter [ __ ] come on get it get it get it
a little better man this is so cool the
adaptive animation of this like I know
it's disgusting and horrible but also
goddamn it don't don't don't be come on
the adaptive animation is just really
cool like the technology is just really
honestly and truly impressive like
that's it's just nuts okay here we go
here we go hey boy hahahaha I'm taking
my stick with me yeah
doggies oh that is so good doggies you
might not want to mess with me I'm I'm
just a little too much for you at this
point pretty sure anyway yep yeah I made
it yeah I don't think those dogs can
handle me maybe the blast of like maybe
the blasting like energy pulse outside
could but this I don't know whoa yeah I
lost some you guys want to come back in
the pile no you okay huh wait what are
you guiding me go left
oh thank you sir thank you
Oh maybe huge oh I see what he was doing
oh good okay I see what he's doing he
was just trying to get me to go left
yeah it's clear buddy oh it's clear yeah
murky did you open it for me no not yet
okay in a second now in a second I'll be
free let's go you count to ten one we
okay thank you thank you sir you're such
a help e Halpert in Hill Oh what if I
don't want to hmm
okay what's over here that anything
trying to hide something from me okay
thank you
man these guys know what to do
apparently headman it yep then an
incineration kill me kill me kill me no
okay
oh I gotta throw it in okay damn OOP no
apparently not okay taking this with me
wherever I may go I honestly didn't
expect there to be a continuation of the
puzzle with this horrible monstrosity
I see uh-huh
there we go got it on the way
good bye people we ha my home territory
in the water oh boy oh boy
where am I gonna go
blam what am I supposed to what am i
trying to burn myself what why would
that be no yeah that's not it
I just toasted some of my buddies yeah I
didn't think that would be it
oh I'm a graceful gazelle at this
juncture but there's something over
there that I need to burn I guess I
should have kept this box with me huh
why though it just seems so bizarre that
this monstrosity has a logic to it I
mean obviously all controlled by the kid
yeah I get it I get it if he is a kid
stop it in their stomach oh now we got a
flaming box oh I know that must hurt
buddy ah damn it
I got throw it over and catch it well
this is some ridiculous [ __ ] but
I'll play by your game you rogue okay
it's a good thing I'm an expert in this
game pit the bin ha ha ha
got it oh oh oh what oh whoa got it I
know I know I'm the best okay
tumble keep it alive keep the flame
alive and then I can light on the fuel
that's like up over there man they're
sprinting to watch their so intrigued by
the horrible monstrosity yeah this says
is flammable okay head blue
okay good I'm just I'm helping out man
all this engineering maintenance I got I
got it on lock I got a lock guys
I'm helping here to help good boy okie
dokie where am I going
I just want to know where I'm going this
is insanity hello can you let me up
please
be awfully nice if you did okay okay
was he waiting for yeah we want it good
so close meant so far okay so he's
waiting on something oh there was a
truck over to the left I didn't even
realize that I should have realized that
what I didn't want
so why was everyone who's running to
watch for one reason or another so there
must have been something to that but I
don't know so there must have been
something happening with this amorphous
blob that everyone was coming to watch
maybe the blob got excited because it
knew that the the the player was coming
you know he knew that he was coming
along and it was about to be time and he
started to get really active or
something like that I don't know I think
he's just holding up the hook so that I
don't get up there like for some reason
here huh okay got it oh ah okay
I'm coming for you baby i'ma coming for
you almost there give me one more try
and I'll be on the way a lot of stress
on those small arms come on gimme gimme
your goodness give me the goods
come on give me the goods come on give
me the guys I'm right there come on oh
oh there we go god damn it huh I knew I
was close I just didn't have it quite
right I was very close but not not 100%
close enough so I need to pull this now
and I should be able to get up and over
on bish do daddy
let me up let me over let me up
let me over think you need to be farther
up need to be farther over okay now I
got it now we're doing good I don't know
if we're still doing good I don't know
if we've ever been doing good here but
we're doing something I think what threw
me off is that the kid had like humanism
human mannerisms cause like he flinched
at the the camera that was looking at
him you know it that sort of stuff
oops oh that's not what I wanted and how
do i how do I activate this thing yep
yeah okay so there's got to be a way to
activate it he's pointing up at the sign
he's like you do it do it man okay but
there's got to be it there's got to be a
way to like turn it on maybe I uh I
gotta give it to him
oh maybe I gotta give it to him he's
gonna give it back ooh give it do it
give it back
do it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey yeah ah [ __ ]
god damn it I was on the right track hit
me get it get it man
get it man thanks man thankfully it just
does whatever the correct route is for
okay
get get get get get get get shibam okay
made it through Wow where am I now what
the hell is happening oh is it this
seems like a trap seems like a trap well
it seems like a trap II oh so close it's
change hahaha oh no did it happen oh oh
oh
oh no oh I can move okay we're good
they thought they had me but they did
not so where am I going from here
what did I grab I grabbed onto something
over there
I'm not sure what I'm grabbing on to you
but it's it's it's something okay can I
fit through here I don't know what I'm
grabbing okay I need to pull from both
sides okay now I'm starting to see okay
so I'm just ripping this thing apart
because I feel like it ah there we go
okay now we got a way out Yes No maybe
so oh come on that's totally a way out
yeah that is I'm try to fool me I know
what it is
yeah little do these guys know I can
breathe underwater for some strange
reason I don't know why but I can and
now to explain why the needle affected
the kid you know what I mean
yeah there's some light up here beware
there we go yeah these guys didn't plan
very well for this [ __ ] oh I almost
missed you guys's vocalizations I hear
like half laughing half crying going on
in here
yeah boy we almost out here
we almost out here baby oh no oh yeah
wait oh do I need to do that again
probably keep Kip Kip haha whoa oh gosh
ow by leaving quite a few body parts
behind now whoa
it's Rock of Ages holy [ __ ] Wow
Wow a little beam of sunlight
I can't I can't do anything I am I doing
everything is what that
is is that the end that can't be
wait something's happening oh my god
that's the end what oh ha ha ha but
something's happening to that blob
it's like shrinking in on itself I think
I don't know what's happening what
happened how can that be the end
what sort of bizarre quest for freedom
was that oh man I bet there's some
questions answered when you open that
cube or another cubed this few but Wow
what in the world that last episode that
last act holy [ __ ] man that was bizarre
oh boy oh boy oh boy
you know I am thinking back I can't even
really remember what the end of limbo
was but man it was a word man I still
don't really get the name of inside even
though I went inside a base and I don't
know man that was made in unity yeah
that's hard to believe considering how
good like it was I mean obviously I have
a bias against he ended the game cuz I
played so many small indie horror game
but it's just like wow
it was unexperienced like that's all I
can really describe as an experience it
was an a journey but I still have so
many unanswered questions I still don't
know why I was doing that I have
theories I have theories that that kid
wasn't really human obviously he was one
of those things whatever they are and he
was trying to get back to that for some
reason and then he wanted that to escape
somehow and got to a beach for a little
sunlight and that's good enough it's
like the only beam of sunlight that's
been in this entire game and it's there
and that's where it went and
I don't know that's symbolism to some
extent that I don't understand but this
has been inside thank you everybody so
much for watching if you know what all
this means or you've opened the sphere
for yourself let me know down in the
comments below
I am a Marine so but thank you everybody
so much for watching I do like doing
series like this I just don't often get
a chance to play a game like this you
know a good one an interesting one more
more interesting than good is important
to me and this one is so interesting and
so well made to like the art direction
the physics of it the animations of it
like all of it just delightful bizarre
but delightful
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching
I guess that is officially the end of it
and that is all for this week so thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video oh you miss me